hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast 3d cell cultures and tissue
clearing a high-content confocal
platform for the complete 3d
characterization of advanced cell models
presented by dr. Michael Johnson chief
executive officer physical incorporated
i am xavier gutierrez of lab routes and
i will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to attain
your credits please join me in welcoming
dr. Johnson I will now turn the
presentation over to him so my name is
dr. Michael Johnson I am the CEO and
co-founder of visit call and our
companies focused on 3d cell culture
models tissue imaging and tissue
analysis before I dive into the
presentation today on 3d cell culture
models and their characterization I want
to talk a little bit about our company
and what it's all about our company is a
contract research organization that's
focused on transforming tissues into
actionable insights our team is
comprised of experts in advanced optical
imaging 3d cell culture models
automation and digital pathology we
currently offer services in three
different service areas in the spaces of
in vitro screening so working with 3d
cell culture models hole mount tissue
analysis so looking at tissues like
mouse frames a whole tissue sections in
3d and lastly digital pathology so
turning traditional 2-dimensional slides
into quantitative insights for
researchers through this presentation I
was in a focus on 3d cell culturing so
talk about where 3d cell culturing came
from background considerations for using
3d cell culture models and assays and
their characterization I was going to
talk about high content screening so how
we actually strap data from 3d cell
culture models what are some of the
current limitations of high content
screening today and talk about three
specific case studies in which we've
used 3d cell culture models in assays
and services at visit call fraud clients
now the most basic question is why three
cell culture models there are many
researchers who've used 2d cell culture
models for years and the 3d cell culture
model space is relatively new and the
question is always asked why are we
transition in 3d cell culture models the
rationale for this the rationale for so
much a research in this area is that
traditionally there's a poor
translational gap between in vitro and
in vivo a lot of results that we see and
be shown
don't actually translate to what's seen
in a vivo and this results in several
major problems reduce in vitro
selectivity expanded in vivo studies
later stage failures where it's very
expensive to fail and unnecessary
screening of compounds that should have
passed on to later stage studies and
lastly increased development cost and
also development time to get a new
therapeutic to market the rationale for
using 3d cell culture models is simply
that biology does not occur within the
body in 2d traditional 2d cell culture
models are great for many applications
they're very high throughput but biology
does not occur in 2d we have gradients
we have all sorts of diffusion gradients
throughout tissues that are not
replicated very well in two-dimensional
cell culture models so this shift to 3d
is having an environment that more
accurately mimics the complex micro
environment within tissues and only
allows us to translate results from 3d
in vitro studies to in vivo studies more
accurately now before I dive into this
and a lot more detail I just want to
talk with a nomenclature so in
publications and in marketing materials
we hear these words steroids Micro
tissues organize and really what they
all
our 3d cell culture models I think a lot
of researchers find these terms to be
quite misleading as we don't actually
have little tiny organs in a dish we
don't have little tiny tissues in a dish
we're actually very far from there and
essentially we have our three cell
culture models we don't have micro
organs just yet hopefully one day we'll
get there but we're not quite there yet
but broadly speaking steroids Micro
tissues and organize are all referring
to the same thing which are a single or
multiple cell types within a
three-dimensional construct that's
usually between 100 and 500 microns in
diameter that can be grow in a wide
array of different ways which I'll talk
about in a moment here now some of the
common techniques for generating 3d cell
culture models are using matrix based
approach so Maitre gel which is very
popular and very common ultra low
attachment plates from Corning n 3d
magnetic printing we're actually using
magnetic nano settles to cause 3d
aggregation of tissues and lastly hang
drops which is another very common
approach for generating three cell
culture models now each one of these
different techniques will really depend
on what type of cells are trying to grow
what your application is and which one
of these is best for your research will
really depend upon what type of question
you're trying to answer and the cost
throughput and ease of use that you're
looking for in a particular assay
there's not one technique that's going
to be best for all applications
something that really stress and to
really drive home here is the point that
3d cell culture models are not a
replacement for 2d cell culture models I
think a lot of researchers are trying to
push the idea these are little tiny
organs and we're replacing all of vitro
studies that have come before but that
is just not frankly true 3d cell culture
models have their place but it's not as
a replacement for 2d cell culture models
for all applications when we're thinking
about designing an assay we're looking
at a couple different things three
primary factors we're looking at cost
relevancy so how well we mimicking
what's going on within the body and
lastly throughput simply put here we're
starting with cell based assays
typically so we're using assays that are
very high throughput they have a very
low cost on a per data basis and the
relevancy also is kind
Lo and as we proceed from having lots
and lots of compounds to fewer and fewer
and fewer compounds we're moving from
cell based assays to 2d cell culture
assays to 3d cell culture to animal
models totally clinical testing and
along the way what we're doing is we're
improving the relevancy we're also
increasing the cost and along the way
we're reducing the throughput so 3d cell
culture models are great they'd allow us
to improve our relevancy but
consequently they're increasing the cost
and reducing the throughput compared to
traditional 2d cell culture models so
they have a good place but it's not as a
complete replacement of 2d cell culture
models now there's some strengths and
also some weaknesses beyond 3d cell
culture models that must be kept in mind
when designing an assay to use them so
it's three to three cell culture models
they're more physiologically relevant
than 2d that can matter for an
application it might not so 3d cell
culture models again are not best for
all applications it depends on your
specific type of research question it
depends on your validation criteria and
the type of cells and the type of
question that you're looking for so we
have heterogeneous cell populations in
3d we have a customizable environments
we have better gradients or more
accurately mimic the environments within
invivo tissues compared what we do in a
traditional 2d cell culture model but 3d
cell culture models it's a very new
space there's not a lot of consensus
around which models are best for which
applications there's a lot of challenges
with labeling with imaging
characterization which I'll talk about
here in a moment and currently there's
not a general consensus on which types
of cell models to use for specific
assays or what types of data that should
be acquired or what kind of validation
requirements are needed for specific
types of models and questions the field
is very new and also ultimately three
cell culture models will always cost
more than three cell culture models and
likely always have a lower throughput
than a 2d cell culture model now I'm
gonna dive into is how do we actually
interrogate 3d cell culture models today
to extract actual insights from the
models because only what we're trying to
do is we're trying to better mimic
what's going on within the body and by
doing that we want to extract data from
those 3d cell culture models and there's
a wide range of ways that we can do it
and again this is
between cost throughput and some other
limitations of the assay itself so the
simplest approach to interrogating a 3d
cell culture model is they use a
dissolution based assay so we're just
taking the 3d cell culture model we're
distilling it down to perhaps one single
endpoint such as total ATP and we're
getting one data point from a well this
is very high throughput the cost is
quite low but in the process we're
losing all the spatial data that
actually makes these 3d cell culture
models more indicative of what's going
on within the body we can also use
chemical analysis which again is going
to get a single data point or a few
single data points from the tissue again
high throughput low cost we can use wide
field imaging throughput here is
relatively high
but the problem with wide field imaging
and a problem with imaging 3d cell
culture models in general which I'll
talk about on the next slide is that if
you're imaging the 3d cell culture model
it is not transparent so if you're
taking a singular picture of one of
these models essentially you're only
taking a picture of the outside of the
model and you're only thinking that
picture on one side of the model be as
if you were taking a picture of the moon
you're only really imaging the exterior
of one half of the moon and because the
moon is not transparent just like a 3d
cell culture model you're only
characterizing the periphery you're not
actually characterizing the entire
population of cells which is very
problematic because the entire 3d cell
culture model is not one homogeneous
structure the different cells of
different components and parts of the 3d
cell culture model will vary greatly and
how they react to a compound or to an
antibody for instance we can also do
histopathology so we can pull out the 3d
cell culture models we can slice them
and do traditional H&E or IHC the
problem here is that this is very low
throughput it's very tedious it's time
consuming imagine trying to slice a 500
micron diameter 3 cell culture model and
acquire a 10 micron slice or 100 micron
slice it's very challenging to do and
it's very low throughput and then lastly
we have conflict with microscopy so I'll
talk a lot about in this presentation
which can be used to actually extract
all the information from a 3d cell
culture model if we use tissue clearing
so if we use confocal microscopy just
like wide field imaging today we're
gonna have the same
which is a 3d cell culture model is not
transparent it has a lot of opacity and
because of that we only characterize the
periphery of these models and not
actually characterize the entire
population so confocal can allow you to
characterize all the cells but requires
tissue clearing to do so and confocal
imaging because we're requiring stacks
of images from one model instead of one
singular image like wide field imaging I
see may be much much slower and more
expensive but we're acquiring a higher
data density from each individual 3d
cell culture model now to expand on that
point and comparing a wide field to
confocal microscopy what I'm showing
here is us using a tissue clearing
technique we developed called visit call
histo M it's a rapid plate compatible
tissue clearing technique that renders
tissues transparent through the
non-destructive process of refractive
index matching so this can be done in
well played it's reversible it can be
done with an automated pipetting robot
but essentially we're removing the water
from the cytosol and we're matching the
refractive index throughout entire 3d
cell culture models which allows light
to pass through unobstructed it allows
us to greatly improve the amount of
signal we can get back from a 3d cell
culture model so this slide here we took
3d cell culture models around 250
microns in diameter that were labeled
with site ox green nuclear stain I went
ahead and image those models before and
after we cleared them with both wide
field and also confocal microscopy now
you see on the right here for spheroids
that are non clears these 3d cell
culture models that are non cleared even
with confocal microscopy
we're only characterizing the periphery
of these models let me go ahead and
actually clear these models imaging with
confocal we can characterize all the
cells within these models instead of
just those in the periphery this is very
very important because if we're trying
to look at how a compound is interacting
with a 3d cell culture model if we're
only looking at the exterior that is
where the compound is that's where the
cells are most limited that's where the
cells are most exposed to nutrients most
exposed to gradients and also most
exposed to compound so that area is
going to be very different from the
interior of the 3d cell culture model
especially so for looking at any kind of
large molecule that has very as a child
time with penetrating into these 3d cell
culture models so clearing here allows
us to characterize about three to four
times more cells in both wide field as
well as confocal microscopy it allows us
to look at the entire population so on
this slide here we're just showing this
graphically so as we go up through the
3d cell culture model and we get to
about the mid plane of a hundred and
twenty microns or so what we're seeing
is that with non-cleared we're only
characterizing maybe 10% maybe 15% of
the cells at that midline but with the
clearing Russian characterizing the
majority of the cells are actually in
that model so we're not biasing our
results today if you're trying to
characterize a 3d cell culture model
using an image based assay you're likely
tremendously 5s in your results and only
characterized in the periphery what's
gonna give you very inaccurate those
response curves which I'll talk about in
a moment here now we designed the 3d
cell culture assay there's a lot of
practical considerations that go into it
the first of which is always a type of
model we get a lot of questions from
researchers about models and what types
of models we have and which types of
models are best for a specific question
and really this comes down to what the
researcher is looking for you can have a
very simple model it is one cell type
you can have a model that is three cell
types primary cell culture it really
depends on what kind of research
question you're trying to answer and
what are your desired endpoints and
what's the desired accuracy of the
models we have to have an incredibly
high in vivo relevancy or is a very
simple Hep C to liver model adequate for
your research question that's going to
drive the price the throughput of this
assay dramatically the next part is
identifying the minimum amount of data
required for a research question I think
this point gets lost on a lot of folks
is that we don't want to acquire tons of
data just for the sake of acquiring data
more data is not only better in this
context the more data we acquire
dramatically reduces our throughput
so for example if we're doing a 4x
imaging run versus a 40 X imaging run in
confocal the amount of data we're
generating is going to be off orders of
magnitude thousand times more data with
one compared to the other and that data
has to process the acquisition time for
why Athena's be much longer and only
this causes us to generate more data
than potentially we need so we're always
very focused on working with our clients
determine what is the minimum amount of
data we need to actually answer the
research question we need 4x and we're
doing 40 X we're spending way too much
time and money on the assay
whereas we get the exact same answer for
our research question with a much more
inexpensive assay labeling analysis we
focus a lot of what types of labels to
use for a research question this usually
goes back and forth with the researchers
we try and optimize the labeling to get
uniform penetration of antibodies
throughout the model and typically we
use three to four labels dependent on
the research question that we're going
after and are heavily dependent upon
antibodies and getting antibodies that
penetrate into 3d cell culture models
and then lastly once we generate this
huge amount of data we focus with our
clients I'm figuring out how to distill
that down to an actionable insight
pretty pictures don't really answer
questions so it's always about taking
large amounts of data terabytes of
imaging data and distilling it down to a
singular report that a client can
actually use to ask the research
questions we focus on this whole
spectrum of questions before we even
start an assay this is very very easy to
go down the path acquiring too much data
or acquiring data is actually answer
your research question for labeling
clear tissues so 3d cell culture models
that have been cleared
typically we label tissues prior to
clearing our technique music all histah
am is compatible of threats and proteins
immuno labeling fish rust of proteins
again felissa probes are at the top here
but thrush and proteins are compatible a
lot of tissue clearing techniques will
quench flushing proteins but we've
developed our approach that actually be
compatible with rust and protein and
amino labeling we developed a number of
techniques to get antibodies into very
dense tissues we've noticed a lot of
issues with getting antibody labels into
their own old steroids which are quite
popular these days and optimized
protocols for all different types of 3d
cell culture models depending upon what
specifically required to get into those
tissues and allow for uniform
penetration a major consideration in
imaging 3d cell culture models is led
or laser excitation this is a new trend
that we're starting to see is
instruments going back to lasers a lot
of instruments initially had lasers they
were complicated they broke down a lot
and instrument dr. switch back to LEDs
and then recently we see manufacturer
switching back to lasers as simpler and
more expensive systems are coming out to
run those high content confocal and non
confocal systems so laser excitation is
really important for imaging 3d cell
culture models and the reason for that
is this coherent light source allows us
to get much better penetration of
photons into our 3d cell culture model
especially if you're using any kind of
you bottom plate like with the Corning
ultra low attachment plates and
instruments like the Aqua Phoenix GN
cell 6000 5500 and the 6 7 LZ are they
have laser excitation which allows much
much better imaging than you get on LED
system where you have a non coherent
light source so we're comparing on the
right here side by side the cx-7 LED
which is a cx-7 system from thermo
Fisher and the six 7lz are the exact
same system with an LED versus a laser
based excitation source and we see a
dramatic improvement in image quality by
using a laser based system compared to
LED based system we use our laser based
system for not only 3d cell culture
models but actually also imaging one
millimeter and two millimeter thick
pieces of mouse brain tissue so laser
allows you to just get much better
penetration of photons in the tissue at
a much better quality of image and one
of the things you'll see on LED based
systems is what we call foreshadowing
you'll definitely see this in a you
bottom plate it'll get a shadow of
excitation below your 3d cell culture
model kinda like a halo and this
artifact is challenging to remove from
your imaging run creates a lot of
problems for image analysis but laser
based systems don't have that issue and
you just get much much crisper images
from a laser based system and that's
consideration we hear about a lot is a
type of objective that you're using to
characterize a 3d cell culture model
most of time we're using 10 or 20 X
objectives these are air objectives
on water difficut the image 3d cell
culture models we can get all the way to
a millimeter if not deeper with an air
objective on our system with tissue
clearing there are some images that have
immersion systems and water immersion or
oil immersion systems and those will
certainly improve your image quality and
your imaging depth but with the use of
tissue clearing that improvement is far
less significant you're actually able to
get much better images with tissue
clearing than you would with a water
immersion or a immersion objective on
its own so we see that it's really a
myth you don't need expensive water
dipping objective the image of 3d cell
culture model you can get by just fine
with an air objective very standard
error objectives with using tissue
clearing now the next consideration is
confocal versus wide field the type of
imaging system to use we do a lot of
assays with both it really depends on
the research question if you need
spatial information from a 3d cell
culture model you're gonna want to go
with confocal microscopy but in many
cases you don't need spatial information
you don't need stacks of images from 3d
cell culture models you just need to
acquire a high quality image in that
case wide field imaging is adequate to
answer your research question it's much
higher throughput you don't get any
depth information but it's much higher
throughput the assays need more
inexpensive and the data densities be
much lower so much easier to process for
a researcher on a per model basis the
next thing we hear a lot about is if
we're using console imaging do we
process deep reductions or do we process
stacks really depends again on the
research question a Z projection though
just for some background is when you
acquire multiple sections Z slices from
a tissue and you compress them all into
one singular image and process that
image that can be useful for some
applications but the problem that we see
is in projections they lose the spatial
information that's inherent in these e
slices you're losing that Z coordinate
by compressing all those slides all
those images into one image and one of
the other things that we see when
researchers do this it's part of the
reason to read a lot of researchers
don't realize the bias and their assay
is when you compress all these images
together you don't actually see
that you're only acquiring imaging data
for the periphery of model you think
you're applying all the data but the
reality you've only characterized the
cells on the periphery of the model and
that's what your characterization is
busy production so again it depends what
your research question is we do a lot of
work with Z stacks so processing data as
three-dimensional spatial datasets and
using that have to answer complex
questions like antibody penetration for
example into a 3d cell culture model now
to dive into some examples of 3d cell
culture models and how they're used I
want to start off with a first case
study on personalized medicine a
question we commonly get again is why 3d
cell culture models one of the things
that three cell culture models do is
they mimic the complex micro environment
within tissues better than traditional
2d cell culture models and in this case
that impact is very significant so we've
taken a wood cell line breast cancer
cell line from Solaria in this case we
took the exact same cell line we grew it
in 2d and we grew it in 3d and what we
see is within the body this type of
tumor will express ER when we grow it in
a 3d self ultra model it expresses the
ER just like it will live within the
body we grow the 2d cell culture model
it does not express a are this is highly
significant because if we ran into a say
with this cell line and we were looking
for this specific type of ER expression
we wouldn't see in the 2d cell culture
model so therapeutics that might work
within the body we're actually going to
screen out because we're not getting
proper expression of ER so we get a much
better expression of proteins that were
expecting and a lot of cases in 3d
compared to duty and you'll see this on
this slide here is that when we have
this would cell line growing in 2d which
is in blue here and we have it grown and
3d which is in red we see for full of
strand which is an ER targeting drug
that fullest trap works very well with
3d cell culture models but it doesn't
really do anything with a 2d cell
culture model we're looking at cell
preparation here which is the marker GI
of 67 so in this case what we're seeing
is that this drug we would not have seen
its efficacy with doing a 2d cell
culture assay we might exclude
from our screen with a 2d cell culture
assay whereas the 3d cell culture assay
we're seeing it work quite well and that
allows us to see that we're getting much
better expression and we're getting a
much better mimic of the complex
environment within the body and 3d
compared to a 2d assay now the same is
shown here with tamoxifen the Matteson
reduces viability in 2d but not in 3d so
really we're trying to stress here is
that it's very important depending on
the research question to mimic the
complex environment within tissues if we
don't do that adequately we can actually
get an answer to a question which isn't
indicative of what's going to happen
within the body the next case study here
is a very simple a saying it's a live
dead assay we've developed a whole bunch
of asset is that leveraged tissue
clearing with us and labeling with
imaging in this case we took Hep C to
steroids grown in Corning ultra low
attachment plates we went ahead and
stained these with Dappy and combined
that with a kit from thermo Fisher for
live dead and then we looked at what
happened after seeding at different
densities so we seeded the ft2 cells
between 500 and 16,000 cells and we
looked at how this chains in the chronic
core over time so we're seeing here is
with a much higher seeding density we're
getting a much more significant necrotic
core so dead cells within the center of
these models as shown in green here and
the reason I wanted to show this is this
is a pretty on exciting application but
it's interesting because a lot of
researchers until recently actually
thought the center of 3d cell culture
models was hollow there's nothing there
it was just absence and what we've shown
is that there are in fact cells there
the reason why a lot of researchers
didn't think there were cells there or
organoids 3d cell culture models were
hollow is they simply couldn't actually
characterize the interior because white
was attenuating either image of these
models lights attenuating past one or
three cell layers and because of that
we're just not getting signal back so a
lot of these researchers who thought
they couldn't characterize the interior
of these models there was nothing there
it was really that they just weren't
getting the data back from the interior
but there were in fact cells there and a
lot of researchers also think that was
impossible to label the center of 3d
cell culture models actually get laid
into these models and again the problem
was imaging getting photons back it
wasn't actually labeling we realize this
early on after our experience of imaging
whole mouse brains who realized the
problem couldn't be labels it had to
actually be imaging and that's exactly
what's going on here we're showing the
ability to look at all the cells in the
population and to characterize in the
chronic core of these models now the
last case study has a focus on here was
looking at Hep C 2 cells and cell
proliferation it's a very very common
assay a lot of researchers do so we're
looking at ki67 antibody labeling and in
this case here we're looking at at
taxall so we're using kayo 67 we're
clearing the tissues with physical histo
em and we're imaging in this case were
imaging with physical histo em with a
confocal microscope and generating those
response curves so here we're looking at
the comparison between tissues that have
been cleared and tissues that have not
been cleared and what we see when
looking at ki-67 for cell perforation
there is a substantial difference
between clearing the model and not
clearing the model the reason why this
is so important is because this show is
that with characterizing entire
population of cells the results you get
are far different than if you're only
characterized in the periphery of cells
which is what most researchers aren't
doing today so if we're looking at only
the exterior we're gonna think cell
preparation is much higher than it
actually is
is we're characterizing the cells that
are most lucrative on the outside of
these models and the show this a little
bit further here and we break down the
three cell culture model into inner
middle and outer we can sort of see the
casi 7% positive cells in each one of
these different parts of a 3d cell
culture model and we see there's a very
very different response depend upon
where we are within the 3d cell culture
model this is very important for looking
at large molecules like antibodies where
we have a very different response
between the exterior and the interior
and if we're only biased are results
towards the exterior the assay is going
to show a very different result that
what's actually happening and was
probably going to happen within the body
so as a company we focus a lot on 3d
cell culture models and trying to figure
out how to best extract
negative three-dimensional information
from these models and again it really
depends on the type of question that
you're trying to answer and the type of
the model you're trying to work with but
again by looking through those different
parameters on how best to develop your
assay how to minimize the amount of data
that you want to acquire you can develop
a 3d cell culture assay that does both
improve your ability to predict it's
going to hack within the body also
reducing costs and allowing your program
to move forward more quickly so thank
you so much the opportunity to present
if you have any questions at all please
feel free to email me at Michael Johnson
at VisiCalc comm thank you thank you dr.
Johnson for the informative presentation
we will now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar and we'll address some of the
most commonly asked questions by our
viewers if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button our speaker
will follow up with your questions via
email all right let's get started our
first question is what is the most
challenging component of executing 3d
cell culture assays I would say the
probably the most difficult part we see
from researchers is depends on the type
of assay they're doing but if they're
doing any kind of imaging based assay we
see the most challenging part is
actually the data processing turning a
bunch of really nice images into
something useful we see this is where
most researchers struggle especially
pharma companies pharma companies have a
really great expertise and what we see
is the biology a lot of times the
imaging is well but when they get to
generating terabytes of data per day
actually distilling that down answering
their specific research question or
optimizing some type of algorithm to do
that we see a lot of problems there are
a lot of challenges so that's what we've
seen probably most problems for
researchers we've actually recently
develop software to address that so
folks are interested in learning more
about that shoot me an email looking for
beta testers to test out the free
software but doing that answering those
questions and taking really pretty
pictures and turning them into a table
or turn them through a report that's
where you see the
got foremost researchers it's a lot of
data process and it's an expertise that
one of Life Sciences just don't have a
background in computer vision or English
processing all right and how do you
choose the right model for a 3d cell
culture asset this is a common question
that we get is um what models do you
guys have your own assays and the way
that we look at this is we're pretty
agnostic on the model we always ask the
client well what is your specific
throughput cost and validation criteria
because you could run a very simple
assay or you can run a very complex
assay with a really complex model where
you have a lot of validation criteria
you've done a lot of assay the valve
that your models actually performing the
way that it should
but for many researchers they don't need
that so I think it really depends on the
researcher we work very closely with
researchers to try to educate them on
this that there isn't a liver model
there are a varying spectrum of liver
models and the one that's right for you
really just depends I think a lot of
companies are trying to move towards
like we see micro tissues and we see
organoids but there's very light
unlikely to be a small tiny liver in the
dish with the next few years it's really
about finding that liver in a dish like
thing that answers your research
question and also meets your costs and
your throughput criteria so I would say
it's really just working through those
questions and understanding the
limitations these are not yet micro
organs that plate all right we have time
for one more question how do you analyze
your data to characterize your model
this depends on like the type of
question that we're trying to answer but
to give you probably those complex
answer or complex apps that we do is if
we're doing conflicts of images from a
3d cell culture model what we typically
do is we use our imager to generate TIFF
files so generating lots of image files
and then from those image files we've
generated a whole wide range algorithms
to answer research questions that we
commonly do for our clients so for
example my most common ones that we get
is co-localization you want to count the
number of nuclei
that expressed for example never cells
and Express let's just say Dappy and
ki-67 and count the percent of positive
kt7 cells so in that case we're looking
at the two different channels we're
putting those on top of one another and
we're seeing where that co-localization
occurs and counting the percent of cells
that express both of those markers it's
a very common question that we get but
all of that processing all that analysis
is done actually externally in software
that we build we've just seen a lot of
challenges with doing 3d image analysis
and how to build that a lot of software
internally that we use with our clients
all right I would like to once again
thank dr. Johnson for his presentation
now I would also like to thank libraries
for for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through December of 2018 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now thank you for joining us
we hope to see you again soon goodbye